[Music]
so look we all experience
emotionally-charged conflicts whether
it's in the workplace with the colleague
whether it's at home with a spouse
whether it's even in our country dealing
with political issues the challenge is
how do we deal with the most effectively
now my Center that most people come in
with like the quick fix answer the
rational approaches just listen a little
bit more talk a little bit less and
that's useful but that's not enough
beneath rationality is this other layer
to the conflict which is the emotional
heir you're starting your angry your
colleague is starting to get angry and
things start to fester but even that is
not the fundamental force driving us in
conflict what's the core its identity at
the end of the day what tends to fuel
our emotions in a conflict is a threat
who we are and what we stand for and the
moment I threatened what you deeply care
about all of a sudden now we have a real
emotionally charged conflict so the
moment your identity feels threatened
all of a sudden you fall prey to a very
dangerous mindset that I call the tribes
effect this is an us-versus-them mindset
you could be in a conflict with somebody
you love your mother your kid but the
moment you get into this mindset it
becomes me versus you us versus them
think about a conflict in your own life
there are three basic characteristics to
this tribal mentality one its
adversarial it is me versus you two its
self-righteous I believe I am right and
legitimate in my perspective and I
believe you are wrong and crazy and
element number three this tribes effect
it is a closed system so I will argue
and defend my perspective to no ends but
I'm going to close my ears to your
perspective this is the tribes effect we
fall into it and stand
dynamic and unfortunately just as true
national dynamics international dynamics
we see the polarization there once you
attach to a tribe something strange
happens no longer is content as
important the substance of the arguments
but positive policies that is important
but at the end of the day the most
important element in terms of being a
part of a tribe is loyalty loyalty to
the tribe and the most serious offense
that you can commit against your own
tribe is to betray that drives trust its
loyalty its essence its to go against
the tribe in some way you look at the
United States right now they're these
huge political divides you see the
Democratic tribe or tribes you see the
Republican tribes as well and it's very
difficult for either side to even say I
understand what you're saying because
some on the inside of each side are
going to say oh no they're betraying our
tribe and the moment it betraying the
tribe that's a taboo if I break a taboo
I can suffer social punishment I'm going
to be excommunicated I'm going to be
ridiculed or worse but that's the
challenge of our tribalistic world that
we're in right now so you could have
somebody in Trump velour Clintonville
who you know totally is getting hammered
by well let's say in the Trump world
who's totally going to get hammered by
the by it changes to health care if
they're still in that camp because the
part of the tribe recognizing that
identity is critical it sort of opens
our eyes to what might be going on in
the world around us and our communities
around us think about some of let's
think about some of the issues that are
in the public sphere abortion health
care taxes security of the country all
of these issues hit right to the core of
our identity who we are and what we
stand for and the moment I feel that any
of those elements is threatened now I
move toward the tribes effect now I want
to move toward being with a group of
people like myself
who are going to protect me and my
interests from becoming trampled on and
a powerful tool you can do is to
emphasize the us the two of us you know
moving from ego to we go you know there
we go and it's a big difference
watching conflict situation I've noticed
something interesting you know what
first people are battling it out my
perspective versus yours and all of the
energy is moving toward my ego and my
perspective versus your ego and your
perspective when you start to see the
transition what starts to happen is that
each side recognizes there's also in us
there's me and there's you but there's
also the space between us
that we are creating together and the
more you can emphasize the us the more
you can move toward real reconciliation
for the two of you moving together
towards some cooperative and sustainable
outcome I mean looking at the rhetoric
in the United States right now there's
so much divisive rhetoric where are the
voices of us the United States of
America and the more you get those kinds
of voices the more you can start to in a
sense overpower the US versus them
thinking we're not trying to overpower
the ideas that the people have behind
their us versus them thinking we're
trying to overpower that adversarial
mindset
[Music]